so you got Demetrius Johnson Marias a
rubber match Rod Tang the best striker
in the world
she the pizza connoisseur Pizza expert
the most technical Jutsu player on the
planet you'll stamp fair tax you have
Roberto Sol ditch RoboCop creation after
you're done listening this make sure you
listen fire kid because Chachi tells a
story about signing him in Croatia and
they go to Crow cop's house and eat with
them and train with them and it's
fantastic he talks about how big of a
star he is you have Sage Northcutt
coming back also one of my favorite
Fighters uh in the world you have RDR
The Savage that's grappling all right